[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free
today hello guys thank you for having me
you're welcome thanks for calling in
what's going
on uh so I'm actually in a big mess uh
so I have a backstory I'm a start there
so you guys understand okay uh about a
year ago I went through a really bad pH
of uh depression and well I made some
dumb mistakes that I'm now paying for
um I got myself into $70,000 of uh debt
I purchased things I I knew I couldn't
afford but I just didn't care at the
moment and well today I'm making uh
roughly about $20,000 a year maybe a
little less than that I am working on
getting my uh CD my commercial driver's
license so I can make more money uh it's
this is really hard to get right now but
to break it down for you I have about 19
or 18,000 in credit cards and uh
personal loans debt okay I have uh
bought a car uh it's a very expensive
car you guys are going to be so angry on
me how much it was $50,000 I now own
46,000 on it and I also bought a
motorcycle that I owe like 5,000 on it
you owe 5,000 on the
motorcycle yeah okay um which do you
want to get first do you want to get
John's take or do you want to get Jade's
take you get to choose but you're gonna
get both uh either
one all right here's the deal man first
thing before you get going I need you
when this call is over to go look in the
mirror and look yourself dead in the eye
okay I need you to say the
following I screwed up but I'm not a
screw
up the game changes right
now okay yeah I need you to repeat that
over and over and over I'm worth fixing
all this stuff okay the funny thing you
call me and Jade 70,000 bucks doesn't
make either of us blink cuz we've both
had way way way more debt than that okay
and both of us have gone through ups and
downs so same team all right um the
$50,000 car that you owe 46 Grand on
that's sold by the end of next week
right yeah and after I sell in the car
already uh I just owe so much money on
it and uh they will only give me like
34,000
so have any money to pay for the upside
down when you look on if you look on
Kelly bluebook.com what's the car worth
or have you done that yet I've done it
yeah uh
$35,000 so it's worth 35 you owe 46 so
10K upside down yeah 9k all right um
we're going to deal with that we're
still getting out of this car cuz at
this point
40,000 is worth it to take a $10,000 hit
so we're going to talk about that why oh
real quick why are you only making
$20,000
man um well uh I don't know how to do
msh um that's not true don't I don't
believe that for one
second not for one second yeah that's
not
true yeah can you deliver pizzas yes can
you drive Uber yes can you go find a
construction site of all those building
sites out in Houston and just throw
brick yes hey yes you don't want to work
you're going to work tomorrow right and
you think that what you know how to do
is not important and it is important
because that's what's going to keep food
on your table that's what's going to pay
off your debt it is so
important yeah I agree are you let's
let's change that hey are you in manuell
yeah I'm in okay we believe we believe
in you and we can't believe in you more
than you believe in you okay yes sir
yeah okay uh we're locking that in so
$20,000 I know you're working to get
your D your you know to so you can drive
trucks CDL yeah but in the meantime
there's almost anything that you can do
is going to make you more than $20,000
McDonald's if you're working 40 Plus
hours a week and I want you working I
mean are you a single guy do you have
kids uh well I have a girlfriend that
don't
count that doesn't count Felicia and
look in this season we're eating at home
in this season it's McDonald's at home
and it's Bob because you don't have any
money okay and let her understand like
hey right now I've got a focus on
getting my life together I don't have
the money to do to I I like you a lot
but I don't have the money to just be
taking you out to whining and dining you
not that you're doing that much anyway
on 20,000 but I certainly don't want you
using a credit card to do that so the
game changes today we're going to get
another job any job I want you doubling
your income in the next month or two all
right and you can do that we're doing
that that's a yes all right yeah next
thing is I want you out of this car
how's your credit I'm guessing it's in
the toilet yeah it's terrible I
completely destroy my credit when I took
all these loans I'm actually miss
payments already I just can't afford to
make those uh to make some payments
anymore on my credit cards and personal
loans yeah I need you so are you current
on the car or you're behind I'm current
on my car uh just because I need the car
I'm I live in a big seat I need to move
around you go sell that motorcycle this
weekend for 5,000 bucks 100% I'm also
upside down on the motorcycle I don't
care how much how far uh they only give
me like 3,000 I owe 5,000 so I'm like
two grand upside if I were you I would
try to get I would try to find the
difference um if you can't get a loan or
a personal loan I try again this is the
one time I'd suggest a credit card see
if you can find you know a 10 or $15,000
balance so you can get out of this car
give them the 10,000 clear the Gap then
take 5,000 to get you a cash car you're
buying a car in cash do your research
get the best car that you can get and
you're going to be $440,000 less in debt
sound
good yeah I I mean I've tried that
already I used to work at a dealership
for like two years and um I know how the
I know how that works it's just that I I
there's no way nobody will give me a
loan for that uh I've tried selling I
I'll try getting a loan for so I can get
another car and drive it around but you
know I'm just too deep in the hole I
guess all right then the next the next
play is I want you to look deeper into
that but the next play here is you've
got to get your income up because at the
end of the day here's what here's what
we know is true you can pay debt off as
long as you stop creating debt you can
dig yourself out of the hole when my
husband and I started out with debt man
well I want you to hear this we made
30,000 combined we had
$460,000 of debt when I tell you things
are possible it's possible but it
demands you getting stupid on this debt
it demands you working so hard to get
your income up and I'm not talking about
overnight this is year over-year month
over month gains you're growing you're
getting better you're earning more money
you're decreasing what you spend and
over time your life is going to change
you're seeing the value and what you put
out into the world and that's what I
need you to get out of this call you can
do it when it comes to your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but
don't tell me that you can't this is the
ramsy show